vous êtes parlés
il m'a tapé sur l'épaule en disant que
mon pote toi tu es mon pote
j'ai dit un petit truc qui est petit
gars t'as pas mes yeux tu es pas
enregistré jamais mon fils
nous allons maintenant poursuivre cette
émission avec un autre témoignage celui
d'Harry Boulogne qui est dans une
situation différente de la vôtre puisque
Harry est toujours lui à la recherche de
son père pour sa mère et pour certaines
personnes de son entourage Harry
Boulogne et le fils d'Alain Delon je
vous invite à retrouver Harry Boulogne
juste après ces quelques images
Harry a toujours vécu écartelée entre
deux mondes celui de ses grands-parents
à Bourg-la-Reine dans la banlieue de
Paris où il a passé son enfance et celui
de sa mère qui donnait des concerts
partout à travers le monde sa mère c'est
cette belle jeune femme d'origine
allemande à la voix si particulière la
chanteuse Nico l'égérie du groupe Velvet
Underground
[Musique]
ce qu'il appelle ses grands-parents
cette Edith Boulogne et son mari la mère
et le beau-père d'Alain Delon qui l'ont
élevé
je dormais pour la reine dans le lit où
avait été conçu Alain Delon et au-dessus
de mon lit au lieu d'avoir une Héma une
image pieuse ou un Christ vous ne croit
il y avait la photo de Alain Delon qui
m'a regardé dormir c'est une des rares
fois où ma mère est venue me voir pour
la reine que voilà d'un côté la maman
d'Alain Delon la dureté du silex
opposait à la douceur du satin
l'histoire a commencé à la naissance
d'Harry lorsque Nico a demandé à Alain
Delon de reconnaître l'enfant de long à
refuser et la justice lui a donné raison
deux ans plus tard Nico malade et
affaibli par la drogue est contrainte de
se séparer de son enfant elle le confie
à Edith Boulogne la mère d'Alain Delon
qui accueille Harry à Bourg-la-Reine et
les ducs comme son propre fils dans la
charcuterie familiale j'ai un pincement
au cœur en regardant ses photos parce
que je fais un bon en arrière de
quelques 35 années c'est ce qui est le
reste de ma petite enfance
des
tirages photos de ma mère et de moi
prise par pomme Mauricette qui était son
grand ami son confident son manager à
l'âge de 17 ans le monde bascule de
nouveau autour du jeune homme Harry doit
renoncer au nom qu'il porte depuis sa
naissance celui de sa mère PAF gun pour
prendre celui des Boulogne qui ont
décidé de l'adopter
aujourd'hui Harry témoigne du chaos de
son existence dans un livre qui est
aussi un chant d'amour dédié à sa mère
Harry Boulogne nous venons de voir les
images qui parlent de vous de votre
histoire alors je rappelle que votre
mère Nico pour elle pour des gens de
votre entourage vous êtes le fils
d'Alain Delon la justice donc a répondu
non quand elle a été interrogée alors
par votre mère c'était juste après votre
naissance puisqu'elle a demandé une
reconnaissance en paternité alors pour
qu'on comprenne bien vous avez vous vécu
une partie enfin une partie de l'enfance
avec votre mère puis un moment donné
vous avez donc été élevé par par la mère
d'Alain Delon et son beau-père monsieur
Boulogne mais qu'est-ce qu'en
grandissant qu'est-ce qu'on vous disait
par exemple d'Alain Delon qu'est-ce que
vous faisiez dans cette famille
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'elles explications
vous donner à vous justement
c'est ma grand-mère quand tu seras
convoqué par qui tu sais
quand tu seras convoqué par qui tu sais
c'est-à-dire qu'elle nous prononcez même
pas le prénom qui tu sais c'était c'est
de long quoi c'est
voilà quand tu seras convoqué par ce qui
tu sais
il faudra que tu obéisses que tu elle
attendait ce moment vous seriez convoqué
elle rêvait de mettre sa main dans la
mienne
ma grand-mère de son côté
ami d'un nourrice à Fresnes parce qu'il
était bringue balais entre là il est
rose qui était le domicile de son père
Monsieur Delon et pour la reine le
domicile de Monsieur
beau-père et qu'il faisait les 400 coups
dans la charcuterie donc il a fait plein
d'institutions privées
donc de ce côté là je peux comprendre sa
souffrance mais qu'est-ce que vous
voulez dire par là que
avec vous il y avait une sorte de
réparation
de d'une enfance qu'elle avait peut-être
manqué avec son propre fils
quelque chose d'impactage qu'il a voulu
rattraper avec moi en projetant tout
l'amour qu'elle avait sur son fils pour
son fils sur moi
Harry Alain harry savait plus sur quel
pied danser elle m'appelait
c'est difficile effectivement pour
s'en sortir
vous avez aujourd'hui 38 ans un enfant
et vous publiez aux éditions Pauvert
l'amour n'oublie jamais
alors c'est c'est un cri d'amour pour
votre mère mais en même temps c'est une
autobiographie qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que vous attendez de ce livre et
pourquoi vous l'avez écrit maintenant
restructurer parce que j'ai eu beaucoup
beaucoup de problèmes d'identification
avec un adoles dont on a bassiné rebâti
des oreilles toute ma jeunesse
et une mère qui était présente mais
qui parle de par son travail ne pouvait
pas s'occuper de moi c'est dire qu'elle
a fait quand même 1200 concerts en 8 ans
mais pendant toutes ces années vous
étiez chez ses parents enfin le
beau-père et la mère d'Alain Delon n'est
jamais il n'est jamais venu vous n'avez
jamais rencontré Anthony poney pour
jouer avec mes jouets
Anthony donc
j'étais à l'école donc pensionnat et
ma grand-mère avait besoin de mentir
quand il lui demandait à qui c'est était
ses jouets elle disait c'est office du
charcutier
voilà
donc des mensonges j'en ai eu beaucoup
oui de sa CAPI donc tout le temps vous
avez été là-bas jamais de contact pas
une lettre d'Alain Delon pas un mot
envoyé une lettre
en réponse à une lettre de
vœux que je lui avais envoyé et où il y
avait de la tendresse
disait notamment je t'embrasse
tendrement
donc
c'est un ni plus rien comprendre en tout
cas vous arrive vous n'avez jamais
cherché entre en contact avec lui j'ai
essayé j'ai essayé à une époque d'aller
le voir
je suis tombé sur le majordome qui m'a
dit qu'il n'était pas là
c'est tout puis je l'ai vu une fois par
hasard chez sa mère à Bourg-la-Reine
donc et il m'a accompagné en voiture à
Paris
il vous a dit ça
donc voilà de toute façon pour la
justice vous n'êtes pas
une coïncidence morphologique rien de
plus mais cependant il m'a dit qu'il
avait couché avec ma mère une fois c'est
tout
mais pour vous ça serait si tout cela
finalement était pour des raisons qui
échappent à tous simplement une
encore une autre histoire effectivement
que de l'eau n'est rien à voir dans
votre histoire même si vous avez
bizarrement été élevé par effectivement
par sa mère par son beau-père c'est
ça me semble tellement ahurissant quoi
que quelqu'un puisse tenir des propos
attendrissants quand on dit je tente je
t'embrasse tendrement
et qu'ensuite ce jeune homme est un
imposteur ou est un menteur
pour vous de passer pour un imposteur là
qu'on n'avait rien demandé du tout mais
qu'est-ce qui est le plus difficile dans
ce que vous dites est-ce que c'est de ne
pas vraiment savoir qui est votre père
d'avoir grandi dans le cul de quelqu'un
dont on vous parlez tout le temps ça la
rigueur ça m'intéresse plus maintenant
ça m'a beaucoup ça m'a beaucoup gêné à
une époque maintenant ça ne m'intéresse
plus peut-être depuis que je suis père
moi-même et que la première chose que
j'ai faite c'est d'aller reconnaître mon
fils à la mairie pourquoi Monsieur et
Madame Boulogne ont tenu à vous donner
leur nom à vous adopter à vous donner
leur nom
vous le dire je ne sais pas
probablement pour ça oui parce que ça
c'est une histoire un peu folle vous
avez le nom
j'ai perdu mon nom Pepe et je suis une
Française je suis passé dans la société
allemande nationalité française
voilà donc à 17 ans ça fait quand même
un choc pendant 17 ans d'avoir vécu avec
un nom et de se retrouver 17 ans plus
tard avec un autre nom vous écrivez
aussi toujours dans votre livre que
lorsque votre mère vous a demandé mais
pourquoi tu t'appelles Boulogne tout à
coup elle a découvert que vous ne
portiez plus son nom vous n'avez pas pu
lui répondre vous étiez paralysé par la
culpabilité
fait comprendre que ma mère était
mauvaise droguée et ils m'ont fait
pointer du doigt comme malpropre alors
c'est ce qui est un peu étonnant c'est
quand même temps ils vous ont des gens
qui vous ont donné de l'amour on a
l'impression que vous leur en voulez
aussi dans le même temps parce qu'ils
ont détérioré l'image maternelle oui on
n'a pas le droit de toucher à
l'imaginaire
quel que soit s'il avait été une
prostituée ça aurait été pareil quoi et
en même temps c'est un acte d'avant de
s'occuper de vous et de vous donner
parce que ce n'est pas rien à un moment
donné de vous donner leur nom j'étais
entouré de d'amour mais d'amour de
personnes d'une autre génération qui de
toute façon mon grand-père fait la
guerre contre les Allemands donc ne
pouvait pas imaginer une seconde
de pouvoir de pouvoir avoir entretenir
un dialogue avec ma mère qui elle-même
était allemande donc une ennemi dans son
inconscient à lui oui c'est ça c'est
carrément c'est même le grand écart d'un
côté c'est la vie d'artiste puis de
l'autre côté c'est c'est la ville de la
reine schizophrénique je dirais c'est à
dire qu'on m'a coupé en deux
nez vous vous avez souhaité arrive
rapprocher de votre mère de Nico et vous
avez vous avez passé toutes les
dernières années
jusqu'à sa mort
voilà jusqu'à l'âge de don de 19 à 25
ans et j'ai quand même une
un combat avec elle c'est à dire que
elle je lui demandait de choisir entre
moi et l'héroïne je lui ai dit maman
maintenant s'il te plaît tu arrêtes le
ruine soit tu choisis soit c'est les
roues soit c'est moi quoi et elle a
arrêté de se droguer
pourquoi vous dites-vous Harry qu'à un
moment donné vous-même vous êtes passé
par la drogue pour mieux vous approcher
d'elle ou c'était la seule manière de
pouvoir communiquer de pouvoir
communiquer en dehors de chez pas
psychiatre je sais pas psychanalyse non
plus
c'était communiqué c'est parce que ça ça
balait les frontières l'héroïne quand on
retrouve justement sa mère à l'âge de 19
ans qu'on ait une image un peu
écrabouillée vous l'avez découverte
j'imagine tout à fait sous un autre jour
je me suis dit que justement il y avait
il fallait pas parler du passé qu'il
fallait maintenant vivre et on a vécu à
fond tous les deux quoi ce qu'on avait à
vivre est-ce qu'ensemble vous reparlier
plus d'Alain Delon je me rappelle d'une
d'un moment où nous étions à Bruxelles
ensemble point de ces concerts nous
sommes restés deux jours et nous étions
allés dans un pub un café à Bruxelles et
là il avait la chanson d'Alain Delon
comme au cinéma il y a de la passerelle
à remettait sans arrêt sans arrêt sans
arrêt comme une petite fille
et là nous montrer un magazine
de lui et pour une parfum parfum Alain
Delon je crois aux lunettes Alain Delon
donc elle se faisait un cinéma de un peu
comme une mini net qu'elle était quelque
part mais d'un autre côté elle était
très très sérieuse alors vous votre vin
a été faite que de rupture donc après le
décès de votre mère des années après
c'était en 95 voilà Edith Boulogne donc
est morte à son tour vous étiez à
l'enterrement bien entendu et alors là
il y avait aussi son fils Alain Delon
vous êtes retrouvés pour
il était nous étions sur le bas-côté
gauche de l'église et lui était sur le
bateau de bas-côté droit plus en avant
avec son fils et un avocat ou un garde
du corps je ne sais pas
et donc nous étions en retraite en avant
et il est parti tout de suite après il
s'éclipsé vite et vous vous avez essayé
d'aller vers lui ou pas ils étaient
tétanisés non j'étais pas tétanisé c'est
simplement quelqu'un veut pas
m'approcher moi j'ai pas aller vers lui
plutôt à lui à mon avis de venir vers
moi est-ce que aujourd'hui vous
regrettez puisque vous dites quand vous
a finalement bourré la tête d'Alain
Delon que vous n'avez rien demandé qu'on
vous a toujours parlé de lui ce que vous
le regrettez qu'il y a eu cette
finalement tout cela autour de vous et
tous ces mots toutes ces références qui
vous aient été données
non j'ai pas de regret du tout j'ai mené
ma vie difficilement je veux dire la
galère c'est quelque chose que je
connais que je connaîtrais certainement
encore pendant un petit bout de temps
mais maintenant j'ai un enfant et c'est
pour pour lui que je vis et une campagne
donc
aujourd'hui c'est votre nom c'est Harry
Boulogne je crois que vous souhaitez
récupérer le nom de votre mère pour me
retrouver j'avais 17 ans
j'étais heureux de m'appeler à hypergen
donc c'est la démarche que vous avez
envie d'entreprendre aujourd'hui c'est
ça
je ne peux pas l'enlever au moins que
Pascal soit rajouté
voilà
je suis désolée d'insister mais pourquoi
vous voulez vous voudriez enlever
Boulogne ça fait partie de vous aussi
maintenant est-ce que vous pouvez le
nier est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on peut
enlever des choses comme ça
arrive à l'âge de 17 ans comme ça que
moi je fais sur la soupe non
c'est j'ai porté ça comme un fardeau le
nom de Boulogne et
c'est un nom que
je dirais je renie j'ai envie de rogner
mais moi et t'oublier complètement pour
retrouver mes racines bon je peux pas
être coupé il y a également des le côté
paternel mais le côté paternel je n'en
parlerai pas étant donné que
c'est défendu
c'est pas défendu mais bon il y aura
j'ai pas envie de mettre le souk
comment on dit
je crois qu'on a bien compris
est-ce que d'une certaine manière ce
livre aussi même si c'est un cri d'amour
vis-à-vis de votre mère ce n'est pas un
appel vis-à-vis d'Alain Delon si vous le
dites NON je c'est une question que je
pose est-ce que c'est une bouteille
jetée à la mer non non je pense pas oui
peut-être mais j'ai droit à mon
à ça et à son contraire une fois Berlin
justement quand j'ai tourné ce micro
icon là ça peut ce film un taxi me dit
mais vous êtes le fils d'Alain Delon et
je dis mais oui absolument parce qu'il
était tellement naturel le mec que j'ai
été sympa et tout je dis oui oui oui pas
de problème c'est moi et puis il y a
souvent d'autres personnes elle a dit
non confondez c'est une méprise j'ai 38
ans et je tiens à dire que
je considère pas que Monsieur Delon et
mon père quoi
moi-même
j'ai pas je suis d'office de mon père et
fils de ma mère oui sans aucun doute
mais je suis avant tout ma propre
personne
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas
[Musique]